what's up guys today we're going to show
you how to make guns look cool cool
alright so today we're also going to
show you how to make your actors look
cool while using them so we shoot a lot
of gun fights and before we shoot each
one there's a few simple steps we go
through with all of our actors on how to
make these fake guns look real secret
it's acting
that's right basically in this video
we're going to go over three main things
your position / pose with a gun your
movement with the gun and how you're
covering the space and then finally how
to make it look real when you're
shooting a big gun so it comes to
filming guns make them look cool the
first thing you want to think about are
lines because guns are basically really
heavily emphasized aligns and you're
going to be composing them as such to
make them look interesting in the frame
diagonal lines strong lines lines
leading to action those are all very
interesting to look at so think about
kind of taking that normal archery shape
as if you are posing sticking your arm
out you want to have framing that really
emphasize the line and mix the line
interesting you know come up with ways
that are really expressing direction
with energy what's uninteresting is
having really weird stances that don't
have any clear line all right this is
good Cup as a sleeve line being drawn
from his eyes to the gun
it's very strongly emphasized yes and
that's because I could actually aim down
the sights now this is bad cop nose mine
here's a mirror no clear line of
direction
Sam's energy is coming from his face and
that's something focused down the gun in
a strong line yeah subsonic interesting
strong lines cool a bow and arrow really
shows you lines more than a gun does
because it's just one really strong line
and you can see how you can frame it
really interestingly and get the line
emphasizing the person's face their
expression what they're concentrating on
and also where they are pointing which
when it comes to guns is very important
when focusing on the direction of the
gun and the line that he's creating with
it a lot of people including ourselves
have made the mistake of accidentally
framing out the end of the barrel
you start having to deal with muzzle
flashes off screen and stuff and so
generally if you zoom out more or pan
over a little bit you get the full
effect because when you see that muzzle
flash come out it only emphasizes that
giant jutting line in the direction that
he's facing so you want to keep that in
mind so when it comes to posing with a
rifle you actually kind of want to think
about it like a fighting stance and
fists up when you're standing like this
knees are bent
you have direction in your body your
arms up and everything's tucked in and
streamlined
and you can really set intensity with
where you're going and that's basically
the exact same pose you're going to take
with a rifle hands are in the exact same
spot if I were to be fighting now it's
worth noting that this is not
necessarily the best actual practical
shooting stance we're filming movies not
actually going out to fight with your
guns this does not necessarily look very
dynamic on camera it looks a lot more
dynamic when you're leaning into a shot
and the gun is tight and your elbows are
in tight and you have direction with
everything you're doing almost as if
you're taking off running or like I say
fighting somebody so a lot of these
techniques apply to pistols in almost
the same way realistically when you're
good fire pistol you're gonna do it from
a front on stance like this you want
even balance you want to have your feet
locked you know you're trying to absorb
the impact evenly as possible however
sometimes it's not very flattering doing
that on camera another way to do it is
very similar to a rifle all you're doing
is just taking one of your feet back
twisting your body and starting to
generate that line again I'm facing my
entire body along the path at which I'm
holding the pistol and so that way you
start generating a slightly more dynamic
pose for the purposes of shooting fake
guns it can look cool so posing with a
gun is a full-body activity a lot of
people get caught and what's going on in
the faith and what's going on in the
arms and they forget about the legs you
stand there like this straight legs
incredibly boring it implies that you
are not going to go anywhere and you are
not prepared for any type of action
always keep your knees bent no matter
what you're doing it always looks like
you're crouched and ready to spring up
yeah has potential
energy yeah didn't you guys play
baseball in your coach ever say you know
you got to be in ready position when
you're out there in the field ready to
catch that ball it's the same concept
when you're crouching and your knees are
bent you're in the ready stance you're
ready to go and how you put your weight
and how you treat your body and how you
twist all lends itself to making things
very interesting and really says
something about what that person is
intending to do and what they are
thinking which in a day so what acting
is all about so moving with a gun how do
you do if you want to keep your gun
ready stable and aiming it what you want
to shoot at all times in order to do
that smoothly you have to do something
that we call just gliding basically you
want to have the weapon lock down and
you want to make sure your feet are
doing all the movement for you you're
not doing stuff in your arms you're not
holding it down here you're keeping it
in a ready position and just making sure
that at any moment you can be aiming at
the right target and fire and be hitting
your target so what this looks like is
like this so I'm orbiting I can walk
around I'm letting my feet do all the
work I'm keeping them bent keep keeping
a wider stance keeping my feet in like a
ready position and what that does is
just keeps everything nice smooth and it
makes it look like I kind of know what
I'm doing so as they say it's slow is
smooth and smooth is fast
so the next thing thing about with
movement is how you are aiming the gun
it's important to show the thought
process that you would actually have if
you are looking for something to shoot
at you or to shoot at meaning if you
have the gun up and you're walking and
you're looking around you need to
actually lock on to something with your
eyes and look at it for long enough that
you can clearly analyze what you're
seeing I see a lot of people in movies
will be walking around doing this kind
of stuff like there's no way they're
processing any of the stuff they're
singing and going way too fast you need
to make it look like you're actually
internalizing what's going on the other
thing you need to think about is your
angles and how you are exposed if you
are in a gunfight and you had bullets
flying around and you're standing in the
middle of an open room this kind of
stuff isn't isn't realistic and you
wouldn't be doing that you'd be looking
for cover you'll be looking for where
you are safe and you'll be looking for
where other people may be hiding to get
you so you want to make sure you're
thinking about your surroundings and how
objects
are keeping you safe and keeping you
obstructed from other people's angles
and how you move around that object can
be really dynamic really tell people and
tell the audience where the threat is
usually I like to just say look with
your eyes and not with your gun except
for work when you're scanning or
sweeping in an environment that
basically looks like this you have your
gun out you can look around you can
sweep search faster you don't you're not
trying to aim down the barrel your gun
at all times with quick tiny movements
however if you do scan or sweep that is
when you're moving the gun Slone up to
where you actually could take a shot
potentially if you needed to
so now I'm going to tell you guys how to
make it look like you're shooting a real
gun when you're not shooting a real gun
at all even in movies and they have
blank firing guns
there's no projectile actually coming
out of the gun causing no actual
kickback or recoil in the gun aside from
maybe a slight shake so now when you
shoot a gun it's not doing this that's
not the action instead it's kicking back
like this and one of the best things you
can do with your actors is have them
hold a gun and take your hand and just
whack the end of the barrel with some
force because that's what's happening
see the motion house can you Sam's body
not a big kick and a straight back and
little jolt that's exactly what Sam
would need to do to sell it the gun is
actually firing so you just imagine a
straight line going from the tip of the
barrel all the way to the first point of
contact on your body and that's where
you're getting the impact from the only
reason the gun Rises is because I'm
shooting the gun from up here not down
there it's my body that's moving back
that creates the muzzle rise on certain
pistols it's because the barrel is above
your hand blah blah blah and I could get
into that
so how do you actually make a gun look
like it kicks well hold it out from your
shoulder just a little bit keep it nice
and loose and then tighten it in pull it
into your body like that and when you do
that that gives us a proper kicking
motion you don't need to go super fast
but that's exact kind of motion you need
to sell and so pistols a little
different obviously you can't pull that
into your shoulders as much but it's the
same concept of the motion so I'm
holding out here Nikko can you help
demonstrate boom boom boom nice and it's
more than just the gun going back it's
about the whole impact in your body and
your stance and everything when I'm
doing this
like you have to kind of imagine the
kick is pushing you back a little bit as
well here's a little editing code tip
for you guys so you're sitting there and
make the gun kick if you want to take a
look at the kicks extra hard cut out
that one frame when it starts to
accelerate and it will make it look at
the gun kicks up really fast so the last
little key to making a fake gun look
real when you're shooting it is how you
are reacting in your face because unless
you're like incredibly seasoned gunman
who does not blink when he shoots
most people will react to a very loud
explosion having two feet in front of
their eyes whether it's just little
blink or a little flinch or just your
face tightens up in that instinctual way
it does and people are like going like
this in your eyes you know you need to
remember that you actually need to
replicate that even though the gun is
not firing that's it so now that we have
the basics covered let's do some gun Pro
tips you've all seen its action that
means you're loading a bullet into the
gun making it ready to shoot if your
character does this right before the
battle like he's really gonna pop up and
shoot a guy right after that
it means he's probably an idiot and
didn't have his gun ready all the way
until that point is a conscious decision
that your character needs to make I'm
going to get ready for battle make sure
you use it at the right time this thing
is not a clip this is a magazine get it
right the magazine is not a handle don't
have your actor hold on to the magazine
it's really silly and everybody will
notice it and comment on it in your
YouTube comments
hold the gun here or my favorite right
here one eye or both eyes open well if
you're using iron sights like these this
is a one eye situation if you're using a
magnified scope that's also one I'd
situation but if you're using a red dot
sight or a holographic sight like this
both eyes open why there's no
magnification and only one eye can see
the target
protip tactical role so hope you guys
learned a lot from our fake guns look
cool tutorial however the last thing you
guys need to know gun safety and a
couple regards hey airsoft guns can
still shoot bb's and those can still
hurt people
be careful treat them like they're
loaded have some be unset checking be
responsible be safe - don't use real
guns it's dumb use fake guns they're
cheap you can afford them point three if
somebody sees you with a gun they'll
think it's a real gun they'll call the
cops or they'll shoot you be smart
here's how you deal with that they post
signs be have a crew up let's see tell
all your neighbors the people in the
area D have a PA or somebody go and tell
everybody e call the police not 9-1-1
call the station it has a regular number
- you can look it up on the internet
tell them you're going to be shooting a
movie and that you'll be doing an action
scene so that if they come if somebody
calls dispatch and says oh my god some
reasons here the gun dispatch thing goes
oh don't worry about it they're shooting
a movie they called in that way the SWAT
team won't show up and shoot you so
smart
also F talk to your parents if you're
too young to be running around the
streets of the gun get their permission
have them tell you where you can go to
shoot figure out an area that's safe and
on private land and doesn't have other
people saying you and you should still
always take the precaution to call
dispatch and tell them you are shooting
a movie like and subscribe and follow us
on Twitter
you